[Music]
donar to understand what effortless
action is you have to understand what
effort is and what effort feels like and
I think the best way to do that is the
so-called Stroop tests so we're gonna
flash a word on the screen and you
should say aloud the color that it's
printed in we don't care what the word
says just the color so here it goes
alright so that was probably fairly easy
did it fast you had no confusion I'm
gonna flash another word down same thing
I only want to know the color it's in we
don't care about what it says so unless
you're some kind of space alien you
paused or you said the wrong thing you
said green or you said green red so that
kind of feeling of having to stop
yourself and override a natural reaction
and then impose another reaction that's
cognitive control
that's effort and I understand very well
from a cognitive science perspective how
this works so part of your brain is
detecting conflict between the parts of
your brain that recognize color the
parts that can read English if you're a
native English speaker and those two are
in conflicts of the ACC anterior
cingulate cortex says Danger Danger we
got to resolve this conflict and then
the prefrontal cortex lateral prefrontal
cortex is brought in to resolve this
issue all of that takes a lot of time so
that feeling of effort you have the it
took you longer the second time this
gives you a sense of both what cognitive
control what effort feels like and also
the limitations of it because it's hard
you're actually a little bit fatigued
after you do that once so when doing a
Stroop test then has less self-control
and if you then offer them carrots
versus cookies as a snack even if
they're on a diet they'll go for the
cookies you self-control that effort
draws energy down when we use it and so
this is why spontaneity is so important
because if we had to go through our
lives exerting effort and cognitive
control all the time we'd be basket
cases before the day
[Music]
whay is early Chinese term that means
literally no doing or no trying but I
think a better translation is effortless
action and it's the central spiritual
ideal for these early thinkers I look at
so the Confucians and the Daoists and
what it looks a little bit like flow or
being in the zone as an athlete so
you're you're very effective you're
moving through the world in a very
efficient way the social world and
physical world you don't have a sense of
doing anything you have a sense of
effort you don't have a sense of
yourself as an agent you can't lose
yourself in the activity you're involved
in and you're not only efficacious in
terms of skill in the world you also
have this power that the early Chinese
call unfortunately the mandarin
pronunciation is duh
it's got a it's this energy you kick off
an aura that you kick off when you're in
a state of away and this is why these
early thinkers want way because for both
of them the Confucians and the Daoists
it's the key to political and spiritual
success so if you're a Confucian getting
into a state of way gives you this power
and this allows you to attract followers
without having to force them or try to
get them to follow you people just
spontaneously want to follow you if
you're a Taoist it's what relaxes people
put some it ease and allows you to move
through the social world effectively
without harm so everybody wants this
because it's a very it's the key to
success but they're all involved in this
tension then of how do you try to be
effortless how do you try not to try
[Music]
the first strategy is the early
Confucian strategy which I refer to as
carving and polishing strategy which is
essentially you're gonna try really hard
for a long time and if you do that
eventually the trying will fall away and
you'll be spontaneous in the right way
so you practice ritual you engage in
learning with fellow students and
eventually somehow at some point you
make the transition from trying to
having internalized these things you're
learning and being able to embody them
in an effortless way the second strategy
the uncarved block or going back to
nature strategy is the daodejing or the
primitive s Taoist and they essentially
think the Confucian strategy is doomed
if you are trying to be virtuous if
you're trying to be a Confucian
gentleman you're never gonna be a
Confucian gentleman anyone trying to be
benevolent is never gonna actually be
benevolent they're just going to be this
hypocrite and so their strategy is undo
all this learning that you've been
taught so get rid of culture get rid of
learning actually physically drop out of
society so they want you to go live in
the countryside and small village and it
looks a lot like kind of 1960s hippie
movement you know back to nature it get
rid of technology get rid of all the bad
things that society has done to us
there's good points to this strategy -
one of the main insights I think of the
Daoists these early dowas is the way in
which social values social learning can
corrupt our natural preferences so we're
you know body images and advertising
teach women that they have to be
anorexic if they're attractive we're
taught that we always need to have the
latest iPhone so you know we have
perfectly good iPhone but then we see
the new iPhone and suddenly our old
iPhone isn't good anymore and there's a
lot of good literature on this in
psychology on the hedonistic treadmill
we're never quite happy with what we
have as soon as we get it we want the
next thing and the daodejing thinks
Confucianism encourages that and
a solution to get off that hedonistic
treadmill is to just stop and go back to
nature and be simple so that's the the
uncarved block strategy then another
confusion comes along main mensches he's
essentially trying to split the
difference between the Confucians and
the Daoists so he says we have these
tendencies so this is the cultivate that
sprout strategy so we have these innate
potentials to be virtuous that are
inside of us but they're fragile they
need help they need to be watered and
weeded to use as agricultural metaphor
which does a lot of work for him so you
need to put effort in you need to try
but you also can't force it and his
famous story about forcing it is this
farmer who is unhappy because his crops
aren't growing fast enough so he goes
out in the field and pulls on the
sprouts to try to get him to grow faster
and pulls them out of the ground kills
them you can't try too hard you have to
try in a way that goes along with your
natural tendencies and strengthens them
and guides them so that's the the
mentioned strategy cultivating the
sprouts
[Music]
and then finally there's a Dallas I look
at at the end who is named Wong's who
thinks that the early Confucian strategy
is misguided the the primitive is
reaction against it is also misguided
because both of them are convinced
they're right and they know the right
way people should live and duong who
says we don't we just don't know
essentially and the only way to live
properly is to make your mind completely
empty and let the Tao the way pull you
along so he has this idea that we have a
force inside of us called the spirit
that is of heavenly origin and is
normally repressed by our mind but we
can get in touch with it and when when
we get in touch with it it guides us
through the world in the proper way so
the famous story from the Jong says this
butcher butcher ding who's cutting up
this ox and it falls apart on the ground
and it just looks like he's doing
nothing and the Lord who's witnessing
this ceremony says how do you do this
and he says I don't do anything all I do
is I shut down my senses I shut down my
rational mind and I let as he says my
spiritual desires carry me along but
essentially the spirit guides him into
the proper way to act and so the the
dong geun's strategy is a letting go or
forgetting just kind of clearing your
mind with the idea that the world will
take you in the right way so if you want
to learn more there are these four basic
strategies that the early Chinese
developed for attaining spontaneity and
I'm gonna walk through each of those
four and talk about both why they make
sense from a religious philosophical
perspective and also why they make sense
from a modern cognitive scientific
perspective and also I know one of them
is actually a hundred percent effective
in all times for all people why we'd
need actually a grab bag of different
strategies to pull from because no one
of them is actually
for successful
[Music]
you